- Thanks to Deep Sentinel
for keeping LegalEagle safe and sound.
Texas files an insane lawsuit
that goes straight to the Supreme Court,
that doesn't seek a recount,
it doesn't seek to add
votes that were discarded,
but it seeks to invalidate
the entire election
for almost every swing state.
- Our request is we want to be heard.
The only place we can go
is the US Supreme Court.
And so we're pleading
with the US Supreme Court.
(microphone feedback)
(bright music)
- Hey, it's Devin from the future again.
So funny story, about
an hour after I finished
recording this video for the first time,
the Supreme Court issued
a summary dismissal of the Texas lawsuit.
So this lawsuit is now dead.
But there's so much that's interesting
about the Texas lawsuit
that even though we now know
the actual result, which
is that this case is dead,
it's still worth going over
what was trying to be accomplished
in this particular lawsuit.
So stick around until
the end of this video,
where Devin from the further future
will come back and actually explain
the court's dismissal of this lawsuit.
A lot of people are calling
this a seven to two dismissal.
It's actually not, for
reasons that I will explain.
But let's actually dig into the analysis
of this particular lawsuit
with Devin from the past.
And I'll come back in the future
to talk about the dismissal
that happened about an hour ago.
Yeah, it all makes sense in a timey wimey
Jeremy Bearimy sort of way.
(eagle cries)
- Hey, LegalEagles,
it's time to think like a politician,
because you don't need
to think like a lawyer
to understand that the
Texas lawsuit is nonsense,
and it's a political stunt
rather than a legal strategy.
Texas filed a lawsuit
in the Supreme Court,
asking the Court to overturn
the presidential results
in Georgia, Michigan,
Pennsylvania, and Wisconsin.
The lawsuit seeks an injunction
preventing the electoral college
from voting on December 14th.
The Texas case was filed
by its attorney general,
Ken Paxton, who has some
legal woes of his own
that we'll come back to later on.
Why yes, that is a mugshot of
the Texas attorney general.
17 other states filed an amicus
brief in support of Texas.
This doesn't technically mean
that they've joined the lawsuit.
Think of it as an aggrieved Trump state
just yelling, "Me, too."
It's a friend of the court brief.
You're adding your authority
and your approval for the lawsuit,
but it actually doesn't mean
that you have joined the lawsuit.
And it will have no impact on the outcome
of this particular lawsuit.
Now, Trump won the popular vote in Texas
and the other 17 states that
have joined in this lawsuit.
The four states they are attacking
gave the popular vote to Joe Biden.
More specifically, urban
voters in those four states
selected Biden at a much higher rate
than now President Trump.
And tellingly, the lawsuit
doesn't ask the court
to overturn any of the other
races on these ballots,
many of which went for Republicans.
It's laser-focused on stopping Joe Biden
from becoming president
by disenfranchising voters
in urban areas and their suburbs.
22 states and Washington DC have now filed
their own amicus briefs in
opposition to the Texas suit.
Now, before I delve into these claims,
here's a quick reminder about
how American elections work,
because it's crazy system,
but it's our system,
and it's important to
understand this lawsuit.
The Constitution's election clause,
article one, section four,
empowers states to determine
the time, places, and manner
of congressional elections.
Subject, of course, to
Congress's authority
to make or alter state regulations.
State and local governments
have the authority
to pass election laws,
including rules about voter registration,
voter protection, fraud prevention,
vote counting, and determination
of election results.
Now, America does not
have national elections,
as we are very cognizant of.
The 50 states run their
individual elections
as they see fit.
And as long as those rules
don't violate the Constitution,
the states can do what they want.
And generally, Republicans
have been in favor
of this patchwork approach
because it allows them the flexibility
in certain states, generally the red ones,
to put in generally more
restrictive voting laws,
often claiming it's necessary
to prevent voter fraud.
And conservatives once
applauded this design
as an example of federalism
and states' rights,
because it gives states the
right to run their own affairs.
Remember when Republicans used
to care about states' rights?
The Texas lawsuit wants the Supreme Court
to turn against federalism and nationalize
the rules for voting effectively.
You can argue that this
would be a good thing
and that our system doesn't make sense.
I would probably agree with you.
But changing it isn't something
the Supreme Court can generally do,
especially after the election
has already occurred.
And you'd have to change the Constitution
to require uniformity in voting laws.
It would require a
constitutional amendment.
Of course, both Congress
and state governments
are constrained by the Constitution
as it currently exists.
But with that out of the way,
let's turn to the Texas lawsuit,
and start at the beginning and ask,
does this case satisfy
the threshold requirements
for Supreme Court jurisdiction?
Now, I'll warn you ahead of time.
We're going to get into
the incredibly sexy topic
of Supreme Court jurisdiction.
So if there are any young
children watching this video,
please ask them to leave the
room or avert their attention,
because it's gonna get
a little out of hand.
But that being said,
Texas alleges that the Biden states
made unconstitutional decisions
about how they decided
to run the 2020 election.
But before we dig into
the merits of this claim,
Texas has to prove that
the Supreme Court can
and should hear this particular case,
because it's very difficult
to get into the Supreme Court.
And as we've often talked
about on this channel,
almost any time someone says
that they're going to take this
all the way to the Supreme
Court, it's total nonsense,
because there's a long,
long way you have to go
before you can get a case
to the Supreme Court.
But Texas has skipped all of that
and they went straight
to the Supreme Court.
And it's not as crazy as it first seems,
because article three, section
two of the Constitution
establishes the Supreme
Court's jurisdiction.
The court has original
jurisdiction over lawsuits
between two or more states.
The court has appellate jurisdiction
on almost any other case that involves
a point of constitutional or federal law.
But Texas is invoking the
Court's original jurisdiction,
which means that this is a new case
that can bypass all of
the other lower courts.
But this doesn't mean that the
Court has to hear the case.
The state has to file a motion for leave
asking the Court to hear the dispute.
And that's what Texas did.
However, Texas went one step further
by applying for emergency
injunctive relief.
Texas says that the Court
should intervene quickly
and stop the four defendant
states from relying
on the popular vote results
and appointing electors.
In other words, Texas would like
the Supreme Court to
tell those four states
that they need to cancel the Biden votes.
And then they just simply
want the small favor
that the Court will force the legislatures
in those four states to appoint electors
who will select Trump,
ignoring what the majority of voters
in that state wanted and
what state law demands,
you know, no big deal.
Now, when the court accepts
original jurisdiction cases
with facts disputes, it usually appoints
a special master to gather evidence.
And this process usually
takes a long time.
State disputes over water
rights, for instance,
have lingered in the
Supreme Court for 20 years.
But President Trump doesn't have 20 years.
So the Paxton Texas brief
argues that the Supreme Court
should hurry up and decide this
with no additional briefing.
That's why Texas argues that the issues
in this litigation are neither
fact-bound nor complex.
But this does bring up
another obvious question.
If the issues are obvious and non-complex,
why did Texas wait until a month
after the election to file the lawsuit?
And why haven't any of the
other lawsuits succeeded?
Now, the Supreme Court's
original jurisdiction
can get complex, but generally speaking,
the Supreme Court has narrowly interpreted
its constitutional grant
of original jurisdiction.
Whether the Supreme Court has jurisdiction
is a threshold question,
which means that the
Court has to be satisfied
it should take this case up
before getting to the merits.
And there are many threshold
problems with this lawsuit.
The first of which is
the question of standing,
which is a topic that
we've covered many times
in relation to the election lawsuits.
The first problem is that Texas
may not have standing to bring the case.
Standing is the ability of a party
to demonstrate to the court
that it has enough connections
to the alleged harm
that it has the right to file a lawsuit.
Generally speaking, to file a lawsuit,
you have to be the party
that was actually harmed.
For example, you can't go
into court and say that, well,
my neighbor's house was robbed
and I wanna file suit on their behalf.
You don't get to do that.
You have to actually
personally have been harmed.
And here, the right party
to challenge election laws
in other states would probably be
the candidates and voters of that state.
It's a little crazy for a state
to say that they were harmed
by what happened in
another state's election.
But President Trump and
the other candidates,
and the voters have
already had the opportunity
to litigate their claims in those states.
But generally speaking, they've
lost all of those cases.
Texas argues that it has standing
because what the other states do
impacts who won the presidential election.
But if that's the case,
then other states should
started suing Texas
because they disagree with
the state's election rules.
It would basically just destroy
the entire concept of standing.
And as Texas GOP Whip John Thune confirms,
"I just don't know why a state like Texas,
which never wants anybody
telling them what to do
now wants to tell a bunch of other states
how to run their elections."
Yeah, it's kind of crazy.
And ding, ding, ding,
ding, ding from the future.
That's exactly how the Court came down,
saying that Texas has absolutely
no standing whatsoever
to be filing this lawsuit
in the first place.
Got that right.
(eagle cries)
But that takes us to the
second problem, estoppel.
The second problem is
that these same claims
have already been
adjudicated in other courts.
There's a legal doctrine called estoppel
that prevents the parties from litigating
the same cause of action or issues
once they've already been
decided by other courts.
It's sort of like double
jeopardy, but for civil cases.
Now, Republicans have tried
to get the Supreme Court
to hear the cases that the
lower courts have dismissed.
But so far, the Court has declined.
And here, Texas is simply
trying to do an end run
around those other cases,
which they already lost.
Which brings us to the third problem,
which is the doctrine of laches,
which means a party is barred
if it unreasonably takes too long
before bringing a legal claim.
And here, Texas complains
about changes to election laws
in other states that happened
months before the elections.
The alleged issues Texas complains about
were also obvious while the
voters were still being counted.
And under federal law, election disputes
are supposed to be resolved by six days
before the electoral college meets,
a deadline known as the safe
harbor, which was December 8th.
The Texas lawsuit wasn't
filed until December 7th,
a day before.
Why didn't Texas do it sooner?
And why didn't Texas
file before the election,
if it already knew what the problems were
in the other states?
And as one of the briefs make clear,
it's because they didn't know
who was going to win the election,
which is the epitome of writing
the quiet part out loud.
I mean, writing the
quiet part in the brief.
It's just crass and unbelievable.
Which takes us to the fourth problem,
which is known as the
political question doctrine.
And to be the kind of matter
that the Court can adjudicate,
the dispute needs to be a
legal one, not a political one.
And when the Court
decides whether the issue
is a political one or a legal one,
it looks to whether the problem
is within the purview of
another branch of government.
In this case, the Constitution provides
that the Congress is the ultimate judge
of the electoral college results.
Republicans are well aware of this,
because they are already
plotting a floor fight
when Congress meets to
certify the results.
So that kind of seems
like a political question.
Which takes us to the fifth problem,
which is the case is arguably moot.
A dispute can become
moot when the controversy
initially existed at the
time the lawsuit was filed,
and it's no longer live
due to a change in the law
or status of the parties involved.
And 49 of 50 states have already certified
their election results
by the safe harbor day.
And the president and his
team of Kraken wranglers
have already been litigating
these issues since election day.
And they've lost basically
every single one of these cases.
They've lost over 60 times.
And arguably, there's nothing left
for the Supreme Court to decide.
But you know what issue isn't moot
is hitting the notification bell.
I was checking my stats
and only 10% of people
have enabled notifications.
It'd mean the world to me
if you would subscribe and
hit that notification bell,
so you'll know when a video comes out.
Which takes us to the sixth problem,
which is that the remedy that Texas wants
to disenfranchise millions of voters
after they've already voted
is probably grossly unconstitutional.
Texas wants the Supreme Court
to extend the electoral college deadline.
The Supreme Court has never granted
such an extreme remedy in a voting case.
It didn't even do this
in Bush versus Gore.
That case involved 537 votes in one state.
- While I strongly disagree
with the Court's decision,
I accept it.
- And this is radically different
considering what's at stake here.
But Texas thinks that the
Republican legislators
in the four defendant
states should be allowed
to cancel all the votes
and just pick Trump.
In our system, the people have a right
to cast votes for the president.
The states in question don't
like who the voters selected.
So they want the Republican
legislatures to pick instead.
That's extraordinary and also
incredibly dangerous to democracy itself.
But all right, let me get
down from my soap box,
and let's play along with the lawsuit.
Let's say that the Supreme Court believes
this suit satisfies all of
these threshold questions,
and then it turns to the merits.
Well, we get into a lot
of the same questions
that we've already talked about
in terms of election lawsuits.
Texas alleges that the
four defendant states
violated their own laws
by changing their election
procedures in 2020.
The theory is that this violated
the equal protection clause
by allowing different sets of voters
to be treated differently
within their states.
Even if this were a valid
equal protection claim,
it would not overturn the
electoral college results,
because the votes have already been cast.
The remedy would not be to
disallow millions of ballots
that were cast by voters
who did nothing wrong.
All these voters did was follow the rules.
Now, Texas and 17 other states
want those votes canceled.
But how would that be
equitable or constitutional?
And we already talked about how bogus
these equal protection claims are
in the context of the Kelly
versus Pennsylvania suit
in a prior election video.
But disenfranchising one set of voters
would present its own
equal protection problems,
especially since the president is obsessed
with what happened in urban areas,
which voted overwhelmingly
for future President Biden.
Texas is arguing that
those votes don't matter.
And AG Paxton is already
on very thin ice here,
because he's already raised all of these
fake election fraud claims
in the lower courts,
which have already been dismissed.
Texas claims that there are quote,
voting irregularities
that would be consistent
with the unconstitutional
relaxation of ballot
integrity protections in
those states' election laws.
And there's a long list of complaints
that we've already heard about.
And generally, which has already
been adjudicated in other places.
Allegedly missing USB drives,
ballots being delivered in food trucks,
alleged statistical disparities,
poll workers doing something nefarious
when other poll watchers weren't looking.
These are allegations that
have already been addressed
in many different jurisdictions.
Almost always, the court finds them
to be completely bogus and made up.
And even if all of those
allegations were true,
which time and time again,
it's been proved that they aren't,
why would Texas have any
kind of standing whatsoever
to make a claim about those allegations?
It doesn't make any sense.
And that brings us to the electors clause.
Texas also claims that
it's unconstitutional
for a state legislature
to delegate their power
to make election laws to state courts
or even to the governor.
Texas claims that by quote,
taking or allowing non-legislative actions
to change the election results
that would govern the appointment
of presidential electors,
the defendant states have
violated the electors clause,
the equal protection clause,
and the due process clause.
And ironically, it turns
out that Texas is guilty
of doing the very thing
that it complains about.
Texas Governor Greg Abbott
extended the early voting period.
Is Texas suing itself?
Spoiler alert, it is not.
But Texas is supported in
these claims by 17 states
who filed the friend of the
court brief, an amicus brief.
These states argue that
it was unconstitutional
for Pennsylvania judges to let
absentee ballots be counted
if they were postmarked by election day,
but arrived afterward.
Like Texas, these states are utterly blind
to their own hypocrisy.
Kansas and Mississippi
also count mail-in ballots
if they arrive late.
So are they calling out their own laws
as unconstitutional as well?
It doesn't really seem like it.
But again, the fact that
states have different laws
about voting doesn't violate
the elections clause.
The Constitution was set up that way.
The elections clause give states the right
to decide the way votes
are cast and counted.
It doesn't give Texas or any
other state a right to veto.
Okay, but enough about
the merits or lack thereof
of this particular lawsuit.
Let's talk about some of
the procedural high jinks.
First, there is President
Trump's motion to intervene.
President Trump filed a motion
to intervene in this lawsuit.
Remember, this was brought by
the Texas attorney general.
Here, the president, for some reason,
is being represented by John Eastman,
a lawyer who is most famous
for writing an article
suggesting that as an
American-born child of immigrants,
Kamala Harris wasn't
really an American citizen.
It sort of goes downhill from there.
But what is President
Trump actually arguing?
Well, quote, despite the
chaos of the election night
and the days which followed,
the media has consistently proclaimed
that no widespread voter
fraud has been proven.
But this observation misses the point.
The constitutional issue
is not whether voters committed fraud,
but whether state
officials violated the law
by systematically loosening
the measure for ballot integrity
so that fraud becomes undetectable.
They're arguing that the fraud is so good
that it can't be detected,
therefore, President Trump wins.
I don't need to tell you
that this is pure nonsense
that contradicts what the Trump lawyers
have been saying for over a month,
that poll watcher saw
the stuff that was fraud,
and that the Dominion voting
machines created fraud,
and that the Democrats injected
fake ballots into the final counts.
Every lawsuit filed by the Kraken says
that she figured out the entire scheme.
But now Eastman argues that quote,
it is not necessary for the plaintiffs
in interventions to prove
that fraud occurred.
It's only necessary to
demonstrate that the elections
in the defendant states
materially deviated
from the manner of choosing electors
established by their
respective state legislatures.
Now, I will point out parenthetically
that perhaps the biggest irony
of this motion to intervene,
where the president
says that he would like
to be a party in this lawsuit actually
may prevent the court from
actually addressing the lawsuit.
Because remember, we talked
about original jurisdiction.
And the fact that Trump is arguing
he has standing to be in this lawsuit,
sort of cast doubt on the
idea that this is a lawsuit
between one state and the other states.
It shows that this case can
and should have been litigated
in the various states where
the harm allegedly occurred
and doesn't need original jurisdiction
before the Supreme Court.
It's the ultimate irony
that by blustering his way into the suit,
he may actually be making it
jurisdictionally impossible
for the Supreme Court to
actually adjudicate it.
Now, you might be saying, Devin,
are these states really suing
because they don't like the outcome?
Well, yes, it seems that's
exactly what they're saying.
This lawsuit is very possibly
nothing but bad faith.
Now, keep in mind that Pennsylvania
has been fighting the same issues
since before the election,
and the courts keep ruling
in the state's favor,
even when the judges are Trump appointees.
But in this particular case,
and I usually don't engage
in this kind of speculation,
it's possible that the
attorney general for Texas
might have brought the suit
for reasons unrelated
to the election itself,
but actually to try and curry
favor with the president
to get a presidential pardon.
As ridiculous as that sounds,
that seems to be the most likely reason
for filing this suit.
Texas attorney general Paxton
has been under indictment
since 2015 on securities fraud charges
relating to activities that
happened before he was elected.
These generally are state charges.
And just for the hell of it,
here's Ken Paxton stealing $1,000 pen
from the same courthouse
where he was indicted.
- [Narrator] This is Ken Paxton,
the indicted Texas attorney general,
rummaging through the metal detector trays
and stealing that $1,000 pen.
And this is Ken Paxton, the
indicted Texas attorney general,
walking away with a stolen pen.
- But then, earlier this year,
he was accused of committing
crimes while in office.
This time, the call came
from inside the House.
His own aides contacted federal
law enforcement authorities
and asked them to investigate allegations
of improper influence, abuse of office,
bribery, and other potential crimes.
Several lawyers resigned,
another personnel say that
they're being retaliated against
for reporting Paxton's criminality.
The Texas solicitor general
who would normally join a filing like this
in the Texas versus Pennsylvania lawsuit
did not sign any of these pleadings,
which indicates that he doesn't want
to be associated with this lawsuit.
And he'd probably like
to avoid being swept up
in Paxton's issues himself.
Now, why is all of this relevant?
Well, Ken Paxton could actually
use a presidential pardon.
He hasn't been charged
with a federal crime yet,
but just this week, the
FBI subpoenaed his office,
indicating that an
investigation is ongoing.
Paxton chatted on the
phone with President Trump,
and then he filed this lawsuit.
But don't take my word for it.
Even Republican Senator Ben Sasse
sees this as a pardon grab.
Now in passing, I'll mention
a couple of the other
amicus briefs that were filed.
These are not binding, they're
not parties to the suit,
but it's interesting that they
filed these with the court.
They want their opinions to be known.
And Montana Governor Steve Bullock
filed his own amicus brief
to make it clear that
neither Texas nor Trump
sought to throw out the selection
of presidential electors
in states that made the same
legal changes to voting rules
as the defendant states, stating quote,
Texas chose not to include
the state of Montana
where President Trump
and other Republicans
were successful in a mail ballot election
conducted to reduce the impact of COVID.
Underscoring, of course, that this action
is less about election
integrity than it is
about attempting to overturn
the will of the electorate.
But if Texas is successful in its suit,
it would destabilize the
results of elections in Montana
and any other state that
took valid state law actions
to minimize the impact
of the virus on voting,
including states that delivered victories
to Republican candidates
using mail ballots.
And then of course, there
were the insane ramblings
of the amicus brief on behalf
of the state of New
California and New Nevada.
I was born and raised in old California.
So I was actually quite
surprised to learn of the 51st
and 52nd state of New
California and New Nevada.
Not surprisingly, this legal brief
is sovereign citizen level,
absolute garbage nonsense.
We're all dumber for having Reddit,
and may God have mercy on their soul
for actually filing this
nonsense amicus brief.
- May God have mercy on your soul.
- Hey, it's Devin from the future again.
And as I promised at the
beginning of this video,
we now have the known conclusion
to this particular lawsuit,
which is that the Supreme Court
has summarily dismissed the suit.
And it did so in two
very terse paragraphs.
The first stating that
the state of Texas's
motion for leave to
file a bill of complaint
is denied for lack of standing
under article three of the Constitution.
Article three of the
Constitution is the one
that just says what jurisdiction
the courts actually have.
It creates the federal
courts in the United States.
And then it says, Texas
is not demonstrated
to judicially cognizable
interest in the manner
in which another state
conducts it elections.
All of their pending motions
are dismissed as moot.
So there you have it.
Texas doesn't have any cognizable injury.
It doesn't have standing to argue
that what other states do is bad
and that it can reverse the
results from different states.
If it has an issue with the way
that things were run in its own state,
or if there are people who
were injured in those states,
then they can file suit
and they can sue those particular states.
But the state of Texas has no interest
in being able to file a lawsuit,
no interest in the legal sense.
Obviously, we have an AG here
who wants to overturn the
results, but in a legal sense,
they don't have an interest
to be able to file a lawsuit.
It's like trying to make a lawsuit
over something that
happened to your neighbor
when it didn't affect you
in any way, shape, or form.
And then, so a lot of people
get the second paragraph
of this dismissal wrong,
which there are two justices that say
that they would have heard the case,
specifically statement of Justice Alito,
with whom Justice Thomas joins.
"In my view, we do not have discretion
to deny the filing of a bill of complaint
in a case that falls within
our original jurisdiction.
See Arizona vs California citation.
I would therefore grant the motion to file
the bill of complaint, but
would not grant other relief.
And I express no view on any other issue."
Really all that saying is
that there are two justices
on the Supreme Court that
say that if a claimant,
one of the states has a claim
under original jurisdiction,
the Court has to hear it.
And there are differing opinions on that.
Some, most of the justices
on the Supreme Court
say that it's discretionary
whether the Supreme Court
will take up the case.
All these two people are saying,
Justice Alito and Justice
Thomas are saying is that,
if there is a case that sounds
in the Court's original jurisdiction,
the Supreme Court of the
United States must hear it,
no exceptions whatsoever.
But almost certainly,
they wouldn't have granted the lawsuit.
They wouldn't have granted the relief.
They still would've kicked out the case.
They're just saying that they
would have heard the case,
not summarily dismissed it.
And here's the thing about
this particular lawsuit.
It was always going to fail.
It was nonsense,
whether the Supreme Court
actually heard it or not
under original jurisdiction
or just bounced it like they did,
it was always going to fail.
And I'm torn on this.
Because you're allowed to file lawsuits,
even meritless ones,
though there are mechanisms
for punishing people
that file meritless lawsuits.
But that doesn't necessarily
mean that we shouldn't judge
the people that filed the lawsuits
that strike at the very
heart of our democracy
if it had been successful.
So to Ken Paxton and the 17 other states
that joined in this case and
the over 100 GOP senators
that supported this lawsuit,
it's their right to do so,
but that doesn't mean we can't judge them
and judge them harshly for it.
But here's the thing, Texas
attorney general Ken Paxton
is still on the loose and
he's coming for your votes
and he's coming for your $1,000 pens.
So you'd better get a great
security system to stop him.
And Deep Sentinel is just that.
I used to live in a house with
a traditional security system
with one of those stupid keypad
where the alarm would go off
if you didn't enter your code in time,
and actually got fined hundreds of dollars
when the police were called out
on false alarm after false alarm.
But Deep Sentinel is different.
Deep Sentinel is the only security system
that actually monitors
your property in real time
and will intervene before
something bad happens.
When the camera detects a visitor,
the guards log into your
system, assess the situation.
And then the loud two-way
speaker lets a guard intervene
and stop crime before it happens.
They can ask the visitor questions
or tell them that the
police are on the way.
It's absolute genius.
And of course, I can
check on all of the status
as it's happening with my cellphone.
And because it's real humans,
there are virtually no false alarms,
because they're actually looking
at what it's happening on the scene.
And of course, Deep Sentinel
is Wi-Fi and app-enabled,
so I can pull out my phone
and check on my front porch
or backyard with one click
anywhere in the world.
And I can turn on the two-way radio myself
and talk to a delivery person
or the guests when they arrive.
And the system automatically tells me
when I get packages delivered.
So if you'd like to try Deep Sentinel,
LegalEagles will get a special 20% off
if you go to DeepSentinel.com/LegalEagle
or use the promo code
LegalEagle20 at checkout.
But this is a special deal.
It's the best deal they have ever offered.
And it will expire in a few days.
So be sure to get 20% off by going
to DeepSentinel.com/LegalEagle,
or using the link in the description.
Plus, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Will this be the last election
lawsuit I have to cover?
Probably not.
Which is why you should
check out this playlist
with all of my other real law reviews
talking about the election issues
and everything that's going on
with the presidential transition.
So click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.